lui lycée jean baptiste un compositeur
baroque
il donne son nom au projet génération
lully un travail débuté en septembre par
le centre de musique baroque de
versailles et les habitants de trappes
un immense travail déjà car au début moi
j'étais papa sais je sais même pas qu'on
aurait le projet me lie à faire moi ça
me passionne vraiment j'adore le théâtre
donc je trouvais que c'était une bonne
opportunité pour moi chaque semaine donc
déjà ça change des fois on fait de la
danse des fois du chant et des fois du
théâtre
génération lully à débuter en 2016 avec
une découverte de l'époque baroque
période des xviie et xviiie siècles
cette année ils ont créé un deux heures
par semaine pour monter baptiste où
l'opéra des farceurs ces farceurs
imaginait toujours des moyens de
contourner les interdits en proposant
des formes nouvelles et inattendues en
se référant à cette tradition là nous
nous sommes dit qu'on pouvait arriver à
présenter un spectacle qui raconterait
de façon comique la vie de lui qui
montrerait comme quoi ça c'était aussi
un sacré tyran pour tous les autres la
création vous fera aussi découvrir les
vaudevilles des petits morceaux de
musique chantée au spectacle encore cinq
mois de travail et les farceurs vous
feront rire
je
c'est là
les yeux